imagine you have a secret code that you
can't crack every time you receive a
message it seems like a jumble of random
letters leaving you puzzled and
wondering what it means but what if
there was a way to unveil the hidden
message enter the hidden Marco model hmm
a powerful tool that can unlock the
Mysteries hidden within data at its core
the hidden Marco motor is like a
detective searching for patterns in a
sea of information whether it's
predicting the weather understanding
spoken language or analyzing DNA
sequences hmms are the sleuths of the
mathematical world what makes hmm so
intriguing is their ability to reveal
hidden States you can think of these
states as the missing puzzle pieces that
shape The observed data just as a
magician pulls a rabbit out of her head
hmms can pull out the hidden States
behind the information you see but how
they do it well hmms rely on the power
of probability they estimate the
likelihood of transitioning from one
hidden state to another based on the
observed data it's like solving puzzle
by analyzing the probabilities of
different pieces fitting together one
fascinating aspect of hmms is their
Markov property this property states
that the probability of moving to a new
state only depends on the current state
not the past it's like living in the
moment and making predictions about the
future without dwelling on the past so
whether you are deciphering coded
messages predicting stock market trends
or understanding the complexities of
speech the hidden Marco model is a
trusted partner in unraveling Hidden
Truths it's the secret weapon that
brings Clarity to the enigmatic world of
data one hidden State at a time get
ready to embark on a journey of
Discovery as you delve into the
captivating realm of hidden Marco model
according to recent studies AI machine
learning related job postings have
increased by 344 in the past five years
companies across the globe are actively
seeking professionals who can harness
the power of data and build intelligent
systems the average salary is 150 000 in
the U.S and 15 lakhs per annum in India
become an expert Ai and ml professional
with the pgp in Ai and ml delivered in
partnership with IBM this artificial
intelligence course caused the latest
tools and Technologies from the AI
ecosystem and features master classes by
Caltech faculty and IBM experts
hackathons and ask me anything sessions
this program showcases Caltech ctms
excellence and IBM's industry progress
the artificial intelligence course
curves key Concepts like statistics data
science with python machine learning
deep learning NLP and reinforcement
learning through an Interactive Learning
model with live sessions
enroll now and unlock exciting Ai and ml
opportunities the link is mentioned in
the description box below
with that having said hey everyone
welcome to Simply runs YouTube channel
but before we dive into that don't
forget to like subscribe and share so
without any further Ado or to our
training experts a hidden marker model
hmm is a statical model utilized to
depict the probabilistic connection
between a sequence of observed data and
a sequence of concealed State it's
commonly employed when the underlying
system or process generating the
observations remain unknown or concealed
which amounts for its name the hidden
marker model the primary purpose of an
hmm is to forecast future observation or
classify sequences based on hidden
processes that generate the data and hmm
consists of two distinct type of
variable first one is hidden States and
the second one is observations
hidden States represent the underlying
variable responsible for generating The
observed data but they cannot be
directly observed but the observation
other side denote the variables that are
measured and observed
so the association between the hidden
State and the observation is established
using a probability distribution
so the hidden markup model hmm defines
the relationship employing two states of
probabilities the first one is the
transition probabilities and the second
one is the emission probabilities the
transition probabilities outline the
likelihood of transitioning from one
state to another hidden State and the
emission probability is describe the
probability of observing an output given
in a hidden state so let's move forward
to the application of hidden markup
model so the first one is speech
recognition
hmm are widely recognized for their
application in speech recognition in
this field hmms are employed to model
the various sounds and phones that
constitute speech that in States
represent distant sound or phone while
the observations are the acoustic signal
produced by the speech and the second
one is NLP natural language processing
so this is the another significant
application of hmm is in NLP in NLP hmms
are utilized for tasks like part of
speech tagging named identity
recognition and text classification in
these application the hidden states are
commonly associated with the text
and the goal is to estimate the hidden
States requires which correspond to the
structure or meaning of the text based
on the observed word the third one is
bioinformatics
hmms find extensive application in
where they are employed to model
sequence of DNA RNA and proteins in this
context the hidden State represent
different types of residues while the
observation corresponds or two sequence
of residues the objective is to estimate
the hidden State sequence which
represent the underlying structure of
the molecule based on the observed
residue sequence and the fourth one is
Finance
finally hmms have also found application
in finance
especially in modeling stock prices
interest rates and currency exchange
rates in these application the hidden
State correspond to different economic
State such as Bull and Bear markets
while the observation represent the
stock prices interest rate or the
exchange rates so after seeing
application of hidden markup model now
let's see some advantages and the
disadvantages of the Hidden marker model
so advantages of hidden markup models
are flexibility hmms are flexible and
can be applied to various domains and
problems such as speech recognition NLP
bioinformatics and final they provide a
versatile framework for modeling
sequential data and the second one is
probabilistic modeling hmms are based on
probabilistic principle allowing them to
handle uncontinuity in the data they can
effectively model and represent the
probabilistic relationship between
hidden State and the observation
and the third one is capturing temporal
dependency hmms excel at the capturing
temporal deficiency in sequential data
they consider the order and transition
between hidden seed which is crucial in
many real world scenarios
and the fourth one is handling noisy and
incomplete data hmms are robust to noise
and incomplete data they can handle
missing observation or deal with data
containing errors or certainties making
them suitable for real world example so
now let's move forward and see the
disadvantages of hidden markup model so
the first one is
Independence assumption
hmms are assumed that the current hidden
state only depends on the previous
hidden State the market assumption might
not always hold in complex real world
scenarios where the current state could
depend on multiple previous States or
the entire history and the second one is
limited modeling of long-term
dependencies although hmms capture
short-term dependency while they may
struggle to model long-term dependency
in sequential data Okay the third one is
lack of transparencies
hmms are considered Black Box models
meaning that the relationship between
the model parameter and the real world
phenomena may not be easily
interpretable understanding the inner
working of the model can be challenging
and the fourth one is model selection
the selection of appropriate number of
hidden States and setting models
parameter can be complex tasks
determining the optimal structure and
the parameter for the hmm often requires
domain knowledge and experimentation so
overall while hmms have proven to be the
powerful models of for sequential data
they are not without their limitation
advances in deep learning and other
sequential model have introduced
alternative approaches that can overcome
some of the disadvantage associated with
the hmms in the specific context
so moving forward we will see
hidden marker model algorithm steps
okay so let's move forward
and the implementation of the Hidden
markup model algorithm can be outlined
through the following steps so let's see
step one
specify the set of possible hidden
States and the observation
Step 2 establish the initial stage
distribution which represents the
probability distribution over the
initial state
and the third one is
Define the probabilities of
transitioning from one state to another
forming the transition Matrix that
depicts State transition
step 4 specify the probabilities of
generating each observation from each
state creating the emission Matrix that
describes our relation likelihood
and the fifth state
train the model by estimating the
parameters of the state transition
probabilities and the observation this
is achieved using bomb Welk algorithm or
the forward backward algorithm the
parameters are iteratively operated
until convex in the east
step 6.
decode the most probable sequence of
hidden States based on the observed data
they want to be algorithm is employed to
compute these sequences enabling
prediction of the future observation
sequence clutch relation or pattern
detection in the sequential data and the
final is step 7.
evaluate the performance of the hmm by
utilizing Matrix like accuracy precision
recall or FNS score so in summary the
hmm algorithm involves defining the
state space observation space and the
perimeter of the state transition
probabilities and the observation of
likelihood the model is trained using
the bomb Welk algorithm for the forward
backward algorithm followed by decoding
the most probable hidden State sequence
using the water B algorithm finally the
model's performance is evaluated using
the appropriate Matrix
so moving forward we will see the small
demo of how you can use hmm model okay
so hi welcome to the demo of hmm so here
we will predicting the weather so
problem statement is so we have the data
of historical data and the on a weather
condition so the task is to predict the
weather for the next day based on the
current days weather okay so let's
import the some libraries before that I
will change the name
hidden Mark of modern okay
so let's import some major libraries
like numpy pandas matplotlip C bone and
the hmm itself so first I will like
import numpy
as NP
and the second I will like to import
import pandas
SPD
then third one is import
as SNS
and the fourth one I like to import from
hmm learn import
HTML okay you have to import or install
hmm Library you can use pip install hmm
and again you have to use pip install
hmmline okay
then one more import
ant matplotlib
dot Pi plot
as PLT
okay let me run this yeah
it's working right so the in the second
step we will Define the model parameters
Okay so
let's define the model parameters it's
like
okay where I equals to
first will be
sunny
okay and rain
okay
so and Para
equals to length of parameters
okay then I would like to print
number of hidden
update
okay
that is and
okay so now here I will Define the
observation space
okay so here I will write observation
equals to
to dry
comma red
okay and and observation
equals to say in the length of
observation
and here I would like to print
number
of
hidden
or that observations
comma
and
observation
okay let me run it
so as you can see here the number of
identities two see you can sunny and
rain and the observation is two or dry
or wet okay so the start probability is
transition probability and the emission
probabilities are defined as arrays okay
the start probability replies represent
the probabilities of starting in each of
the Hidden State the transition of the
probabilities represent the
probabilities of the transitioning from
one hidden state to the another and the
emission probability is represent the
probabilities of observing each of the
outputs given in a written state so in
initial stage
the distribution will be defined as a
state probability which is an area of
probabilities that represent the first
state being sunny or rainy the state
transition are defined as the transition
probability which is two by two array
okay so it's like this so let's
move to the you know defining the
initial State distribution and all
so here I will write Para
probability
pursue and P dot array
0.6 comma 0.4
I will write here print
the
error probability
okay
and
then
Para
probability
okay so here I will Define the state
transition probabilities so I will add a
transition
probability
because you NP dot array
and here I will write
0.7 comma 0.3 it's like 70 30 percent
okay
then
point
three and point seven
okay
so now I will print
see the transition probability so I will
write trans underscore probability
equals to NP
dot sorry
about comma
trans
probability
okay here we don't have to write
underscore
yeah so now I will Define the
observation likelihood so for this
emission
emission probability
equals to NP dot array
it's like 0.9
comma 0.1
then
then I will write zero point
two
and let's give 0.8
okay
so here let's print the emission
probability
Mission probability
emission underscore program
okay
and let me run it okay NP array
trans probability 0.7 0.3 okay
uh okay so here let's add
okay
yeah so as you can see the para
probability is 0.6 to 0.4 then the
transition probability and the emission
probability
okay
so let's create an instant of hmm model
and set the model parameters okay so the
hmm model is defined using the hmm
categorical hmm class from the hmm
Library we
already imported the library hmm learn
and incentive so here the set of n
hidden States and the parameters of the
models are set using the start prop okay
so let me do
for this for the better visual
and here I will write
model equals to hmm Dot
categorical
hmm
and
and underscore components
equals to
and parameters
okay then m dot start
probabilities
okay this
this Para
okay if it better understood probability
okay
then
m dot
transmit underscore
equals to
trans underscore probability
then m dot emission
emission
probability
equals to emission
underscore property we already defined
here as you can see the trans the para
probability the emission probability
okay so let me run it
okay
and comp
it's n components
components
so now let's define an observation
sequence so a sequence of observation is
defined as the one dimensional numpy
array so the observed data is defined as
observation sequence which is sequence
of the integers representing the
corresponding observation in the
observation list
okay so here I will Define observation
sequence
equals to NP
dot add a
0 comma one
comma
0 comma 1
comma 0 comma zero
okay then dot d shape
and then minus 1
comma 1. okay
so here let me write observe okay
okay no error so I can
so it will give me the output as you can
see it's coming in like one dimensional
array okay so moving forward let's
predict the most likely sequence of
hidden States so for that we have to
write here
hidden
date
equals to
model
dot predict
observation sequence
okay so print
hidden
bit
okay so it's not the model
it is m
so as you can see it's coming okay zero
one zero one one zero okay so the most
likely demonstrate is this
it's coming like this
so now what we have to do we have to
decode this observation this zero one
triple one double zero observation using
the Y Derby algorithm Okay so
for that we have to write here log
probability
[Music]
hidden
it's hidden state
okay
equals to m dot decode
observation
sequence
comma
so length
lens
it goes to length of
observation algorithms
equals you
y to B okay
so here let me print
the log
underscore probability
and
print
the hidden States
okay
okay so land takes Noah keywords are
good one okay so for that we have to
write here
observation
underscore algorithms
again
okay
so here I will write observations
sequence
right before
Okay so
observation sequence OBS sequence okay
oh yes sequence so let me run it
it's saying length
okay
quite a b
and then it's
print
Ed no keywords arguments
I'll go read them
and the observations
okay I forgot one thing
it is sequence
we can write actually like this
okay then comma
yes let me run it down okay it's coming
so as you can see the log probability is
minus six point this and the hidden
state is this
so this is a sample like how the algo to
implement the basic hmm and use it to
decode an observation sequence so let's
plot the results
okay let's see
so SNS
dot set
nine
grid
okay PLT Dot Plot
hidden States
comma
minus o
X
K level we don't want to write
okay we can write the label also
so here label equals to
and then instead
then PLT dot X label
time
and PLT dot y level
like most likely
hidden state
and here
PLT Dot
title
is sunny or
rainy
and then
PLT dot Legend we can write
and then PLT dot show
okay
so let me run this
okay so here we can write the white grid
so as you can see finally the results
are plotted using the matte broadly
Library where the accesses represent the
time steps and the y-axis represented
the plot shows that the model predicts
that the weather is mostly sunny with a
few rain days mix so as you can see it's
mostly runny
Sunny okay see zero one one sunny and
then these are the hidden States and
these are the zero again okay as you can
see zero one triple one double zero
okay
so
this is how you can implement
hit a marker model in your projects
so these are the some
Library I use the numpy pandas and the c
bond
okay
and here we uh you know
so here we describe the parameters and
the observation and here the probability
we get and here we implement the hmm and
here hidden States now finally okay so
here we wrap up with this hmm model okay
if you have any question please add it
in the comment section below where
expert will get back to you soon so and
do subscribe to Simply learn channel for
the more updates till then stay safe and
keep learning staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upskilling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in Cutting Edge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the description to know more
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learned YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here
foreign